et dès ce matin la violence a fait place
à la polémique le maire de la ville et
les commerçants ont accusé les policiers
d'être intervenue trop tard le reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux jean marc pitte
et georges mines angoy l'émeute s'est un
peu calmée reste les dégâts et vient
l'heure des comptes pour le seul centre
commercial presque entièrement ravagé
les dommages pourraient s'élever à plus
de 20 millions de francs aujourd'hui
assuré experts étaient déjà sur place
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
contacts avec votre client intermarché
bien sûr et ce du conte se réinstaller
ici à côté je crois que sa décision
n'est pas prise et il apprendra pas
aujourd'hui toute la journée les
habitants de la commune sont eux aussi
venus constater le résultat de la colère
des jeunes
c'est la surprise qui domine même si
leur quartier avait déjà mauvaise
réputation auprès des autres communes
il était rare à penser qu'on puisse y
aller si loin je recense deux événements
indigents comme un
un choc c'est pas normal de voir tout
gaspillage si maintenant des commerçants
ils veulent partir d'ici il y en aura
toujours qui seront là pour reconstruire
ça devrait arriver à longtemps ça arrive
maintenant ecoffi suivre des soins je
suis vraiment alors fixé ces conneries
un peu ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont dit
les grands chaque fois qu'il y aura un
meurtre ça se passera la même chose